[Music]
get it fair news you give up wait I
didn't use and is it fair news okay
summer I like cereal meet you a dating
app hopes to help singles by banning
users with criminal records even if they
have a minor offense that's [ __ ] hmm
I like this but what if they're looking
for that bad boy happy for you can I ask
y'all ladies a question though yeah why
is it okay Melissa Lunden
yeah I'll speak for them whatever is it
when the ladies who are younger or also
uncultured
[ __ ] you [ __ ] click I can answer cuz
you already know where I'm already
knowing where you're going to go what is
it it what what is so attractive about
the dark side
let me can't answer please can I answer
and then you guys could tell me if I
don't know you do know because ok how
many how many dicks have you sucked out
of valedictorians none right so you guys
go for the sky too just kidding so you
guys if you type of persons we go for
the scum what is it about the reason is
when girls are young they don't know the
difference between confidence and big
[ __ ] egos and guys that just go
against the grain and break the rules
and a little bit fat they're like wow
risk a equals Wow competence and then
you know what happens they get horny
here's the wedding because you wanted to
see that so bad is that true lady they
don't know the difference of real
confidence I don't think I've ever been
with a bad boy really yeah what do you
cost you that bad [ __ ] messages
I now get with him and all that how many
Harvard grads have you [ __ ] just
because they're not Harvard grad doesn't
mean they're bad yes they are but you
Eliza how about let's analyze the fact
that you get really
when he talks about being really
aggressive inches uh that I like men a
what does that mean there's so many
genders nowadays do tell me what is a
manly man I like kind of someone that
behaves like a Neanderthal a little bit
you know like a barbarian yeah you got
that so my boot off I like yeah yeah
like I michael rugged so was that
[ __ ] clamp
fish like this and walking that's a high
personal prayer way too special
I prefer barbarians but none of the
boyfriends that I ever dated are like
breaking the law our life disrespecting
people they do drug it - they [ __ ]
disrespect apparently not when I was
with them yeah not when I was with them
so I don't know I don't think I know
people that break the law they're not
disrespectful uh well that's in my book
is classified as a bad boy yeah for
people that's not something you bring
home to mom let's just put it like I
don't know about thank you though like
this
we have bars all of you Barton Wicca
which the first here we go it's yeah
we're gonna get rid of his criminal past
okay it is gangster ass violet sexy
behavior okay no personality we go
between those tattoos right okay tattoos
doesn't make you a while ago okay then
we're also going to remove those
pectoralis muscles I'm out I'm out you
lost me disconnect okay but he got the
same dope sense of humor the same
[ __ ] business mentality then yeah I'm
still in but I would have to make him go
to the gym but you don't want to he's
all about developing this versus this I
need a balanced man I need a balanced Oh
dad you shallow [ __ ] oh don't you
honest about it though maybe a shallow
but I did I don't think it for
aesthetics I see it for capability what
you mean like but we're not in a Stone
Age you might not be but if I want to go
on a hike I don't want my men do honey
you don't even like hunt where you
talking I'm not like you okay oh we're
talking about
she doesn't like hard you like running
yeah I didn't like Ryan she likes
physical act but she likes walking in
the forest physical activity - but he
doesn't like that about to be like he
does right now
yeah I guess I try to give you a little
I can't outperform my man is what I'm
trying to say
oh so you say you try like that no I'm
just saying the person I go with can't
be weaker than me but at this time
though you probably wouldn't be as
strong as you are now why are you not
meeting him the way he is but I've
always kind of been like above the
female average just cuz of my bill I
think that he would still be stronger
than you know oh they're not fine there
were were label okay what if your equal
strength oh I can't do that you think I
can do it what if you were better than
him at something but he was better than
you at something ah
like what if you could lift more than
him no I can't do that but he could
[ __ ] out eat food more than you know
I think because I'm attracted to
barbarians
he needs to be stronger than me what if
he can out cardio you uh he needs to be
a Barbie did she likes a rhino versus a
gazelle what if he can lift more than
you yeah but then he can't sports more
than you Oh cuz you know what sports
takes finesse yeah that's okay so you
play basketball better than him
everything better even fighting better
but then he can lift like a mofo so I'm
strong but unathletic oh I think any
hand eye coordination such as I think I
could work with it as long as when he's
doing it he doesn't look dumb
that's a little harder to do an athletic
partner has eye coordination part I
guess I just need a superhero I don't
know you like bad boys try think back in
high school and if they're after hurdle
yeah it's to every girl bone but like if
I could think about I didn't turn in my
homework today Julia yeah I feel like me
being attracted to the bad boy type it's
more of out of curiosity than trying to
like success well can I always had white
bread I know white bread good yeah what
the [ __ ] does rye bread taste like yeah
yeah because it's just like do they have
different dicks because like much in my
world everything feels so safe and like
for all the other people that have
similar problems with me it's like I get
you but I'm trying to
than this person what's going on with
this person [ __ ] their [ __ ] I don't care
about the number two pencil on the test
yeah I know your pastor she likes bad
boys she didn't like to be a bad
situation
that's her turn on dude to put me in a
[ __ ] bowl little place in my life
right yes sir if I was right or not was
I right or what I don't know I can't
tell ya I can't answer yeah we're not
basic [ __ ] dabbling everyone's basic
at one point though everyone is yeah
okay fallopian okay so like you know
that raw primal thing that you're
talking about
I want a barbarian I think these bad
boys trigger that raw primal attraction
from young girls that's why I think so
too
hmm but they just don't know that the
others got like criminals
cuz okay yeah because there's you know
it's more like Oh risky man that doesn't
give up yeah yeah yeah I just remembered
when I was in high school and I was
going through my trophies seeing like a
bald head and baggy pants and like shut
up you would turn me on
yeah like [ __ ] yeah bad right yeah good
a lot of the realest things ever
there's a lot of girls I feel that way
but they don't they don't say I'll say
hmm but that's one of the realistic ever
like in high school guys loved the
import model look yeah the [ __ ] booze
she ain't got no eyebrow just a line
doesn't cover her body at all she looks
like she's worth [ __ ] $2.00 an hour
no I so anyways we're talking about this
app here I will just show you their
little promo ads it's like about 27
seconds long find a rapist you can suck
in your area there's no criminal record
you get into this Epson I asked after
the video let's do it same song at
Gatsby we have amassed billions of
publicly available data records
our entire country our advance risk
algorithms look specifically for bad
boys criminal history she surrounds them
meaning someone new should not be
foreboding and costly it to be fun and
exciting and a change and to join the
face remover with Daddy
who was it that did tell me got that
nothing man presentable whitey yeah they
scream every single person that tries to
get involved in this app that's cool
because I would like to know if a girl
had a restraining order on her and she's
[ __ ] nuts oh my god you may be born
Internet you just don't know so I mean
like knowing that information about that
app couldn't people create big profiles
no they're gonna scan databases make
sure that you've got a real social
security I see so they actually give to
a background check on you and they say
it takes about three seconds for them to
do that and they're saying that the
reason why they're saying anyone with
any sort of a sense is because it would
be a really hard judgment call to
determine like oh this crime is okay
that all they're just like no criminal
activity at all if you were arrested but
didn't have any charges against you or
anything and then you wouldn't be
filtered out I actually want to know
like we should make a dating app that
ties the two types of criminals together
a recipe for bad news let me like you
know not all crimes are created equal
you know like sometimes it's like oh hey
crime
what kind of hate crime racial hate
crime oh let's get together and talk
about hating people like what if it's
like the minor offense people like
traffic violation DUI people they're all
like man we're a different group so
we're going to be on this side we just
like to drink and drive it responsibly
group you know or like graffiti like
like hey we're just we're not real
criminals reaches the law doesn't agree
with us so then they're one group I
don't know maybe if people don't really
want to date people based on their
criminal activity yeah it's kind of like
eHarmony oh yeah you get to know each
other better
hey imagine you get two rapists together
female rape is in the mail
rapists they just rape each other oh-ho
that's driver dream comes ready this
saves the world yep yeah get two
murderers together guy murder a girl
murder they could kill each other oh I
could team up and tell more people no
but I love there's not gonna happen that
way yeah it has to be yeah it has to be
love you have to match them correctly if
I said one that daddy issues Dylan has
daddy issues doesn't got kicked outta
for school doc you gotta forth it's
going to be a match made in heaven yep
and then they're going to love each
other like crazy for some reason I
thought that's apples for for you to
find people with criminal records so you
could date them the opposite I kept
saying that oh [ __ ] well let's [ __ ] this
Adam look cool ones looking for bad boys
yeah a girl exactly I think that would
be a lot more realistic felon yeah
because some some no like not all crimes
are created equal I agree sometimes
you're like oh that was a pedophile get
that fool away from me like oh he does
only bank heist that's it though he had
to do other things I'm cool with that
he's rich he's honorable he's a bank
heist kind of guy he's got morals hmm
he's going places like jail how's it
going guys don't forget to like the
video because if you don't I will break
your [ __ ] legs thank you so much for
the last videos don't forget to click
right here or I'll break your [ __ ]
arms click right here guys
[Music]